[Música]
como quería
sería un sueño tener una pasión el
objetivo me llevó a mí como joven porque
no tenía a médicos atrás me motivará a
convertirme en una publicista en este
evento nacional de bellas artes porque
tenía 20 años yo tenía un grado en el
objetivo no quería ser publicista quería
trabajar en ser publicidad quería entrar
en la mejora de hacer publicidad
es algo decente
[Música]
y
de la nada por razón de la vida del
destino empecé a prepararme lo mejor
también se ha publicitado de honduras
entonces y me encantó la rutina porque
podía pagar ligas
teníamos seguro médico
tenía los de todos modos de los que
estamos aquí buscamos a tener
estabilidad estabilidad económica de
estabilidad emocional y me iba a ganar
grandes premios
publicidad pero esta vez
de por mérito y yo construyendo los
sueños pero pudiendo construir los míos
cuando me cae el mexicano en cuenta
interrumpido en camino a mi destino por
situaciones y decisiones que yo misma
y cuando un voluntarioso
involuntariamente me convertí en más del
entonces ya no seguía sin pensarlo solo
gente que tenía que pensar en la
estructura porque madre soltera y tenían
que sacarnos adelante con ciertas ayudas
de padres diferentes con ciertas ayudas
de uno de los padres
pero toda la carga recaía sobre el
objetivo de destino
y decir estoy construyendo del sueño
ahora quiero construir
algo muy curioso que nosotros nos en el
camino como estamos en esa disyuntiva de
qué voy a hacer cómo lo voy a hacer
porque lo voy a hacer muchas personas
y una de las personas más importantes
se concederán otras las personas no
importa el frío
yo tenía sin pensar yo decía
impresionante
en el nombre de ese país una vez me dijo
usted va a conseguir todo lo que te
propongas
y impresionante porque mecano con esta
persona y yo tengo que conseguir cómo
realizar mi pasión
hoy cuando
lo que quería hacer
y decir
voy a vivir
de la pasión es el arte
y se encargó de informar
porque es mi vida
[Música]
mi pasión como
no está segura trabaja dedicar a ser
incluídas
no ahora
[Música]
y van a vivir
y es que los otros verdes
sí
[Aplausos]
y voy a evitar y como sea voy a morir
pintando como me forma el destino
de cuatro años
y un consejo de comunicación
impresionante tenía amistades colegas en
días y se descargaron publicidad de
redes sociales donde hablaban de lo que
yo crea que trabajo
de cojera posible
dos amigos y
y dice lo que dice la prensa
ahora no quiero agregar vamos a ser
invitado 6 mientras lo dice que según
reposición en el segundo año
[Música]
pero antes
ya no era el tiempo en que se había
lanzado la nueva cabecera registrado
no soy artista
es mi pasión
levante
yo aproveché
hoy vamos a cambiar
[Aplausos]
con destino para mí
una moral
dónde
yo ya es una expresa
el destino
habrá motivos para seguir gritando para
seguir evolucionando y es una inversión
para mí
pérez o forma se va convirtiendo en un
camino llamado éxito
d
el éxito de esta velocidad
el camino
como artista
entonces a dónde quería llegar a quien
quería llegar
a mis hijos y que pondría sobre mí y
sería más
el mondeo promedio
y le pregunté
ustedes creen el destino que es el
destino
y esta pregunta se la digo a ustedes
independientemente
tengan tres hijos cuál es su destino
se ha de seguir camino
claro
y en ocasiones jubilosos que lo sienten
a él
ahora ellos tienen que formar sus
destinos
tengo mis consejos yo sigo trabajando un
destino y le estoy infectando una idea
de destino a ellos porque
periodo es porque mejor a buscar
el tiempo
y el tiempo
por qué estás haciendo con su tiempo con
quién están sintiendo en un tiempo vale
la pena ver tienes el tiempo pero estaba
haciendo yo me dijo sí
pero
conocidos
producida unidades cargadas
como no se puede esperar
y hacerse
[Música]
gracias
yo
y emprendedores
por qué
al suelo que tenía a lo que yo tenía
para casa
primero
y para mí
para mí
es que en nuestro país
este lugar
en serie de artistas emergentes y tres
personas como la que está llevando a
pasar que le dijeron no
y hasta mensualmente
yo solo solamente tiene niños como dice
un abuelo mañana quiere la tierra
usted no les tiene que importar lo que
tenga que decir el vecino que no tiene
que importar lo que decida la familia si
ya se les digo se encargó de trazar el
camino lo único que tienen que hacer
encaminarlo
una vez llega caminando los 10 donde
todo el carnaval una demarcación
pero yo esté viendo la manera en que se
levante
me encantó cuando yo miré el estado
había se iba
es
y
claro que no había mente
porque no sé
y el entrenamiento vida
serían alguien aquí están sentados
sí
[Música]
y les voy a decir
el azote
el arte
cómo equilibrar como la vida de las
personas
y ya
y destruimos el sol es por miedo que
puede contener
lo que no tiene
como la de ahora
la fórmula 1
no hay fórmula
es la conexión en el interior
la dirección
en favor de
a realizar hoja de vida como artista
facilitar los mecanismos para hacer para
conseguir patrocinadores así como
elementos así como artista tiene que
entender también para poder levantar
sus presentaciones no difiere en nada
entonces nosotros las manitas eso tener
más constancia si quiero ser artista
porque para mí porque la entidad y
honduras necesita habilidad
honduras necesita color honduras
necesita dentista las grandes sociedades
inscritas se ha levantado a través del
arte porque nosotros vamos a hacer la
selección porque nosotros no vamos a
verlas no vamos a fijar esa mirada
delante para levantar la sociedad para
levantar vitalidad prevención en cultura
de reversión a los que están ahí
porque vamos a buscar el poder
hay que decir todos
pero
y el que me encuentre lo siento mucho
elegir es el momento de abordar abordar
su destino encargarme en el nuevo llevar
las riendas
soy el presente soy el presente y con mi
trabajo que ha servido para llamar la
atención ya sea para generar conciencia
como este trabajo que dice que se llama
regreso a las series
que era sobre esas personas
pero también es mucho más garantista
también encaminados
a exportar la velocidad que nosotros
tenemos los horarios
como podemos también
abstracto también puede ser lo que
tenemos hasta que permitió presentarse
en taiwán y con buenos aires en honduras
y en las presiones más importantes
desafíos la atención
para recibirlos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
podemos rescatar a nosotros mismos como
sociedad porque nosotros
con embarazos
niña y encuentro ha salido
tengo la batería con este propósito
y días
[Aplausos]
nuestra unión en las escuelas públicas
y medio
[Aplausos]